hey everyone diavalo here and in today's
video i'm going to be going over the
final and most intense arc from
throughout the entirety of demon slayer
this arc started off with a literal
explosion of action and from that point
onwards it really felt like it could go
either way as time slowly started to
take down closer to the final sunrise
this arc here is of course and nothing
else but the one and only sunrise
countdown arc of the george roopingly
stunning demon slayer series but just
before we continue make sure you hit the
subscribe button and leave a like on the
video as it really goes to show that you
are loving these demon slayer and just
entire series explained videos in
general but anyway enough of that let's
get into part two of the final arc of
komitsu no yaiba tanjiro regains
consciousness and sees the night sky
above him finally back at the surface
after yushiro had worked so hard to get
them all there realizing that they were
in the middle of a city tangible panics
and karaya ubyashiki sweat while saying
that they were flying much further than
he had expected he asks his sister how
long until dawn and she tells him that
there is still an hour and a half before
daybreak karia's eyes widen at the
knowledge that there's still so much
longer left acro tells the demon slayers
how much longer they have left until
dawn and taking note of the fact tangero
looks around to confirm that his
comrades are doing alright relieved that
the hashera who had been with him are
all safe tanjido moves out to find muzan
suddenly the demon lord bursts through a
pile of rubble sending it flying in all
directions enraged muzan taunts the
demon slayers and dares them to keep him
there until dawn if they can even do so
he launches a wave of attacks that the
hashera all evade and then begin to
attack muzan obani with the serpent
breathing third form coil choke and
matsuri with her love breathing second
form love pangs geyu then attacks with
the water-breathing eighth form
waterfall basin obino manages to slice
through muzan's neck but is surprised to
see that his blade goes through the
demon and is unable to leave any damage
he realizes that he is regenerating the
instant they damage him at once muzan
resumes his attacks on all the hashera
however he is pushed back by the junior
demon slayers who wish to give their
lives to take out muzan all of them
begin attacking him together and quickly
make an opening for those who are able
to fend off muzan giving them a chance
to survive the hashera are horrified at
the chaotic battle scene and their
subordinates being killed one by one to
protect them tanjuno struggles for air
unable to keep fighting due to the pain
of his words muzon explains that those
who die immediately from his attacks are
fortunate for even a wound would be
fatal those who die from them will
suffer a greater pain he nods towards
tanjido as the boy lies on the ground
writhing in pain with a tumor growing
out the entire right half of his face
saying that he mixes his blood into all
of his attacks muzan tells tanjido that
he won't become a demon since the
concentration of his blood and his
attacks is too high he would be poisoned
instead destroying tangero's cells and
ending him tanjulo continues to writhe
in pain grabbing his throat as muzan
confidently declares that the boy is
dead zekonji shakes with fear as nezuko
wakes him up for the second time as soon
as she opens her eyes he asks her what's
wrong outside tengan uzowi and shinjuto
look on in shock as an izuko somehow
begins to run away uzu yells after her
asking where she's going while his
colleague shinjuru reports to karai
ubishiki that the girl had begun to run
away karaya was afraid that muzan might
be influencing her but he felt his
father's hand on his shoulder the voice
reassured karia that it would be okay
and all he needed to do now was let
neziko make her own decisions karate
ordered them not to follow her to their
initial consternation as if she were
caught by a demon they would be able to
retrieve her however he tells them with
tears in his eyes that his father had
told him it would be alright niziko is
faster than sekonji and he loses her
just as she leaps off a cliff after
being pointed in the direction by her
father's ghostly appearance as she lands
safely sekonji is shocked to see that
tamiya's medicine to make her human
again had not worked elsewhere geyu
obernai and matsuri continued to battle
muzan who had manifested his malevolent
presence over tanjido's face the tumor
can be seen growing just above his eye
they're all struck by this but muzan
unleashes another flurry of attacks and
commends them for still being able to
move
however those with demon slayer marks
would not fall so easily mathuri's wound
flares as she is unable to move yelling
at her companions to protect themselves
muzan's outstretched whip is suddenly
cleaved off by gyome to matsuri's relief
the stone heshira apologizes for being
late as muzad recognizes him as the
demon who slew kokushibo he is suddenly
taken aback as he is sliced clean down
the middle from behind by sunimi who
also flings a few bottles of oil towards
the demon who slashes them and gets
drenched in the liquid tsunemi backflips
away and lights a match midia throwing
it towards muzan setting the demon on
fire
muzan cries out that senemie played a
dirty trick to which the hashera
responded that it's the perfect fit for
the demon saying he will grind him to
smithereens murasa peeks out from the
rubble at the scene and geyu notices him
yelling at him to carry tanjiro to
safety as the boy is unable to move
touch that gui remembers his name morata
carries tanjuno forward as the boy
begins to dream while envisioning the
past tangier is back at home with an axe
in hand chopping firewood but he is
shocked that he cannot smell anything
tanjuno notices he is in a home that
looks similar to his own and not
actually his own confused at the fate
that has befallen him he comes across a
nearby man who is bowing respectfully
before him he realizes this must be the
swordsman of the first breath yoruichi
tsukigoni meanwhile morata is doing all
he can to resuscitate tangero's physical
body he was unable to find a pulse and
the heart had stopped beating back at
the home yetu reveals that he came to
speak about what was on his mind and he
wanted someone to listen tangier wonders
if it involves the 13th form he says
it's been two years since they last met
and he's glad that yoruichi is doing all
right tangier was surprised to see this
but he also noted that sumade had grown
up since they last met he realizes that
his actions and words are those of his
ancestor sumi yoshi meaning he cannot
interact with them you know which he
states though that he is happy to see
him happy saying he is happy when he
sees other people happy and believing it
to be a blessing to be born in this
world his mother was a very religious
woman who often prayed for peace in the
world she would pray to the sun god to
shine on his ears back when he was
considered deaf he worried her when he
couldn't speak as a child something that
only got worse with his age his brother
machikatsu was a kind boy who always
worried for him despite garnering abuse
from his father for it even gifting him
with a handmade flute the day his mother
died yoda which you ran from the house
knowing that he was unwanted and he was
to become a priest of the temple as well
as ensuring mishikatsu would be the
rightful era he ran as far as he could
seeing the beautiful night sky but
despite running for almost an entire day
his feet never became tired soon after
urdu your witchy came across a young
girl around his age standing alone in a
paddy when asked about what she was
doing she sadly states that her entire
family had died of a plague leaving her
the only survivor she wanted to take
some tadpoles home for company but she
remained unmoving for the rest of the
day and as the sun began to sit she
decided to release them unwilling to
separate the tadpoles from their
families urduisu offered to take her
home with him and as she looked at his
face he saw that her eyes were dark like
obsidian the girl's name was utta and
she began living with yoruichi she was
talkative capable of speaking for almost
an entire day while he was quiet but uta
taught him how different he was to
normal people she stated she had never
met another person who could see inside
a living creature like yoruichi can this
enlightenment lead him to realize why he
always felt like an outsider but uta
cared for yodawichi greatly he
considered himself like a kite with a
cut string she grabbed it and held on
tight ten years later yoruichi and yuta
had married and yusu was pregnant
expecting her first child soon yet at
which he went to get her midwife to
prepare for the birth while hoping to
return before sunset while out he
encounters an old man attempting to
cross the mountain despite being in poor
shape the man's son was wounded in
battle and yoruichi took the man to see
him for his final moments
deciding to fetch the midwife the next
day he ran home as quickly as he could
but his son had already seen it yet
which he found utah had been killed by a
demon along with the child inside her
belly as they shocked tangero listens
you to which he comments that even if
something is more precious than your own
life others can easily trample over it
he spent 10 days absent-mindedly
cradling the corpses of his family until
he demon slayer chasing the demon had
found him he told him that he believed
the two should receive proper burials
all he ever wanted to do was live with
his family in a small house he wanted to
have the photons close together at a
distance where he could see their faces
or easily reach out and grab their hands
it would have been enough for him but
that dream would never happen he sadly
says demons exist in this beautiful
world yet at which he became a demon
slayer shortly after this learning
people had been chasing demons for a
long time yet nobody had used breaths
like him so he taught them how they
worked the best swordsmen were known as
the hashera and now armed with the new
breaths of flame water wind and stone
their powers increased even further they
began killing demons like never before
yetawichi also adding his own brother
had also joined upon the deaths of his
subordinance soon after yudowichi came
face to face with the originator of
demons muzan kibitsuji and he finally
understood upon meeting him that he knew
he had been born for only one purpose of
defeating that man
after crossing paths with muzan due to
which he immediately senses his violent
intent comparing it to magma erupting
from a volcano muzan instigates the
confrontation by stating his disinterest
in swordsmen that use breathing
techniques shortly after he unleashes
his attack and attempts to kill him
though yet which he dodges the attack he
knew that even if a single strike hit
him it would be fatal by seeing through
muzan's transparent body urduchi was
able to discern that he had a total of
seven hearts and five brains despite his
immense power yuduichi manages to
complete his sword forms and combine
them into a single attack overwhelming
muzan completely as tanjiro through
sumiyoshi listens to the story he
realizes yuruiji had created the 13th
and final form of sun breathing despite
trying to regenerate his body muzan
becomes stunned and is forced to hold
his head in place to keep it from
falling off yeruichi realizes that the
immense amount of damage was caused by
the bright red blade that he wielded he
questions muzan on what he believed the
value of life to be only receiving a
furious glaring response believing his
words didn't reach him yodewichi's
attention is then drawn to the young
demon girl traveling with muzan he
immediately notices her eyes staring
directly at muzan not with a look of
concern but with a look of hope as he
sat there dismembered holding his
severed head before he began dealing
with her yoda which he approaches muzan
in order to finish him off however as he
walks towards him the sound of teeth
grinding grew louder until muzan's body
burst into many small pieces caught off
guard due to which he was only able to
cut about 1500 of the 1800 total bits of
flesh leaving the remaining portions to
regenerate somewhere else and escape the
girl collapses on the floor and begins
to weep while tearing out her hair and
angrily cursing that muzan should have
died she is then surprised that she
managed to survive despite seeing
muzan's name out loud due to it she
approaches her and calms her down before
she eagerly informs him about muzan how
he was the originator of demons and
would most likely never appear before
yeruichi again he asks for her
compliance in defeating muzan to which
she agrees and allows her to escape she
introduces herself as tamiya to yeruichi
something that tanjuro is surprised at
after his interactions with the demons
yodoichi is approached by the demon
slayers whom inform him that his brother
michikatsu had become a demon once they
return to the estate he is angrily
confronted by the rooster the swordsman
for failing to kill muzan for letting
tamiya escape and for michikatsu's
transformation into a demon as a result
he was banished from the demons air
corps and was demanded to commit sega
poo but the newly assigned oyukasa would
not allow it to happen after telling
sumi yoshi the end of his story
yidawichi reveals his thoughts of being
born with a gift to defeat muzan but his
failure to do so and that because of his
mistake many more people would begin to
perish at the hands of muzan telling him
it pains him distraught by his inability
to comfort his friend for going through
so much
yoshi sits beside yarawichi in silence
until summerday slowly walks towards the
swordsman she takes softly on his
clothes and says hug surprised by the
child's sudden demand sumiyoshi asks if
his guest would mind carrying her to
make her happy without her response
yodewichi picks up the girl and lifts
her up into the air the little girl
squeals with a delight of happiness
causing yoroichi to emotionally break
down and his eyes filled with tears soon
after suyuko returns from gathering
chestnuts in the forest and discovers
yetawichi weeping as he hugs the little
girl suyaku comes forth to comfort
yoruichi saying she'll treat him to a
warm meal
back in reality as tanjido sleeps he
wishes that yoruichi's heart would find
any form of peace after hearing
everything that the man had to go
through after a series of attacks from
muzan gyomi comments on how he appears
to be getting faster so fast that
matsuri barely manages to dodge his
attacks on pure intuition and luck
perform it so they can land an attack
she realizes that she is getting dragged
down by one of muzan's arms another
attack from her manages to slice off
some of the hashera's right cheek and
injure the shoulder of her right arm
overnight jumps to rescue her and with
the help of sunimi geyu and gyome
holding museum back he is able to carry
her to another demon slayer he commands
the slayer to find yushiro to treat her
injuries and the slayer agrees however
matsuri insists on fighting but obanite
doesn't allow her as he leaves her she
pleads for him not to die
as he's running obani contemplates the
number of people that have had to die or
because of the existence of demons at
first he wishes that he and matsuri had
met under normal circumstances but takes
it back saying that he would rather die
and claims himself of the filthy
bloodline he carries within him his
bandages fall behind him as he's running
to reveal the slits across his cheek in
a flashback it is revealed that his
family stole and lived a luxurious life
from it obanai was the first male born
into the clan in over 370 years and was
confined to a cell because of this he
would have died earlier if it wasn't for
his different colored eyes as the demon
living there with the lower body of a
serpent decided that he should grow to a
more satisfying size before she'd eat
him she was also the one who ordered the
other females of the clan to cut the
sides of his mouth to resemble her as
obinna was trying to get away kabu
ramaru his snake friend head straight
inside the cell before their escape
using a hairpin urbanized slowly cut
away at the wooden cage and they were
able to slip out soon after because of
him the serpent demon killed everyone
else in the clan and tried to kill open
eye but shinjuro the flame heshira of
the time katu head off saving obanai and
his female cousin by becoming a demon
slayer he felt as though he could become
a better person even though the souls of
the dead family members always dragged
him down
obernairy states that he would like to
die by killing muzan to purify his blood
and hopes to meet matsuri again in
another life one without demons saying
that if he and her are ever reincarnated
into humans he'll confess his love to
her neziko continues to run towards the
location of the fight as the group of
kukushi attempt to keep the sight of the
battle clear of civilians and redirect
all approaching people to safety they
tell them that they are rescue teams set
by the local policemen another group of
kokushi examined the rubble of the
buildings destroyed by muzan's attacks
and find that no one has been harmed due
to the damage except for a cat trapped
in the rubble after freeing the cat it
ran off to the battlefield with a bag
strapped to its back this cat was no one
other than tamios over at the fight
obani and tsunemi battled muzan at close
quarters and opener chopped off one of
muzan's arms cleverly kicking this away
as he severed it to prevent the demon
from regenerating immediately muzan
notes the strategy as well but is
unconcerned saying that the extra time
the demon slayer has brought is but a
blank muzan attacks obanai with his whip
and the hashira rules all the energy is
having to waste just to avoid the mouth
of the werp he assuredly thinks that he
will only allow himself to faint one
second after dawn as every second is
precious and has been brought with the
lives of all of the members of the demon
slayer core geu begins to weaken as a
result of the venom he has received from
all of muzan's attacks and disorders
whipped away from him by one of muzan's
attacks obernai and gyome intervene
slicing the creature with sunimi
grabbing his sword and throwing it near
the water shearer and yelling at him to
focus or else he will kill him himself
geyu gratefully grabs the sword and
performs the water-breathing third form
flowing dance resolving not to back down
and keep fighting until the very end
muzan admits that they are more
resilient than he had expected but is
unconcerned as it is only a matter of
time before his venom kills them all
long before dawn the hashera continue to
struggle against muzan as the poison
continues to weaken them until suddenly
tamiya's cat jumps onto the scene and
injects its cargo vials of antidote to
muzan's poison it manages to file all
the vials at the hashera and they
immediately begin to inject the
antidotes into them as this happens
muzan slices the cat into pieces sanemi
smiles as he notices his tumors
disappear and guilleme also notices his
frenzy pulse and constant pain vanishes
the hesherah are able to fight with more
ease again which sunimi is thankful for
gourmet notes that it is possibly just a
temporary cure for the symptoms but that
they are fortunate for such an event to
actually happen muzan quickly deduces
what had happened and realises tamiya
had done it cursing her for being a
thorn in his side even in death with
immense fury he launches a frenzied
attack that creates multiple craters in
the landscape ahead of him the heshira
all barely managed to dodge the attack
with obanai wistfully thinking to
himself how his contribution has been
the lowest wishing he could land more
crucial blows thinking that when one's
life is in danger one is able to exert
explosive strength he reflects back on
how before he had never lifted anything
heavier than a pair of chopsticks and
his biggest task was escaping a prison
cell he couldn't believe it himself when
he had successfully done so and thought
of what machiero did in his final part
against kokushibo by changing the colour
of his sword according to the crows all
he would have been able to do was grip
his sword tightly saying he had been
shocked when he heard about it and at
first believed it had changed colour due
to a rise in temperature however now we
realized that to obtain a bright red
blade he would have to grip his sword
with all his might and grit his teeth he
put all his strength into gripping his
sword and it slowly began to shift from
its usual colour to a bright red obinae
reflects on how he saw stars in his
peripheral vision when he saw the bright
red blade and realised he had made a
mistake recognising that he had been too
fixated on tightening his grip on his
sword and gaining the bright red blade
to the point he had almost passed out
due to lack of oxygen he was brought
back to earth with a yell from sunimi
who warns him to watch out as muzan
launches an attack his way noting that
even if one of them falls it will
increase the burden on the others obinna
tries to stand up and fight willing
himself to make out for matsuri's
absence however he has lost feeling in
all parts of his body except for his
sword hand guillo attempts to intercept
muzan's attacks but he isn't able to
outpace the demon's blow suddenly he
looks up and sees open eye in the air
having somehow successfully dodged the
attack muzan sees this and attempts to
attack him in media but is shocked to
see the serpent hashera dodge easily
again further surprised at his right arm
and whoops being cut off seemingly from
nowhere muzan notices that there is an
odd kind of cut that could not have been
made by the weapons of those that he is
fighting muzan forcibly regrows his
severed limbs with a delay then resumes
his attack to stop gyome and sunimi from
getting into close his further surprise
as his left arm is chopped off as a
result of a similarly mysterious cart
muzan deduces that it has to be from a
blade with jagged edges and realizes
that someone else is present who is also
aiming to destroy him quickly assessing
the new threat muzan analyzes his
surroundings saying that even if a spell
from tamiya's demon could make someone
invisible it could not erase their
traces of existence though he is unable
to see any silhouettes through the dust
clouds muzan is still able to hear the
air passing in some areas deducing that
there are three hidden attackers around
him he slices at their approximate
locations and is able to land a hit on
all three of them inosuke kano and
zunitsu suddenly pop into view as
muzan's attack slice off the seals on
their heads they are taken aback and how
quickly he was able to find them out
bakuyami is pleasantly surprised to see
that they are all still alive inosuke
boasts that he won't die and that he has
plenty of seals to spare muzan
unceremoniously interrupts enosuke's
monologue and swipes at him with a whip
but his attention is drawn back to
himself mid-attack as obanise slices off
both of his arms he is displeased at the
time it takes to regrow from these
attacks by a bright red blade and sunimi
is heartened as he notes this fact to
his companions
zinitsu hurriedly put on new seals and
attack muzam with flower-breathing
fourth form crimson hanago moro and
thunder breathing first form thunderclap
and flash enraged muzan calls them a
bunch of pesky flies saying that they
have nothing but pitiful tricks but he
is interrupted by obanai who attacks him
with serpent breathing third form coil
choke while this happens guyme thinks to
himself that this addition to their
numbers and obani manifesting a bright
red blade has helped them and it also
allows him to concentrate more the
stonehishera clangs his weapons together
and upon impact both of them change
colour to a bright red he swings at
muzan and knocks off his entire left
shoulder exposing his spine the demon
pauses and sunimi yells geyu to prepare
himself as he swings his blade at gilus
turning both of their weapons bright red
as well a crow arrives overhead and
announces that dawn will break in one
hour and three minutes with this tsunami
declares that there is no problem as
they will chop muzan into pieces yushiro
injects tundra multiple times with the
antidote to muzan's poison made by
tamiyo in an attempt to rejuvenate him
the demon slayers around him ask if
injecting tangero so many times is safe
for him he quietens them and says that
his condition has been worsening since
muzan struck him the demon slayers try
to free tanjuro's katana from his hands
but he has a very tight grip on it so
they fail yushiro takes this as a sign
that tanjiru still has the will to fight
and suddenly the demon slayer holding
tangero's head yells out saying that he
had felt his pulse return they attempt
to wake him up and when one of them
mentions that muzan might get away they
are all left completely stunned as
tanjiru's katana begins to creak as his
grip on it tightens considerably and he
jolts back awake back at the fight with
muzan akakushi hidden out of sight peers
over to see how things are faring and
gets hoped that they might hold out
until dawn gyome cleaves off the left
half of muzan's torso and sunimi rushes
over to a pile of seals on the ground
and puts one on his forehead as soon as
he put it on he could see kanoa zinetsu
and inosuke as inosuke declared that he
wanted a bright red blade like the
hashera tsunemi launches the
wind-breathing seventh form gale sudden
gus towards muzan guyame is relieved at
the arrival of the new fighters as it
allows him to concentrate more looking
into the transparent world he sees that
muzan has multiple hearts and brains and
thus will not die if they chop his head
off he also knows that they move around
his entire body making it difficult to
actually strike them an idea suddenly
strikes him believing that if the others
could also see muzan in the transparent
world they will be able to strike the
organ simultaneously and destroy muzan
for good he calls out to the others to
look closely at muzan's body and see if
their vision changes and if they can see
through him for an instant obani is able
to do so and is shocked at the sides he
doesn't have long to ponder this idea
however as muzan launches a devastating
attack in all directions and crushes
everything around him flinging everyone
into their surroundings the kakushi is
shocked at the sound and looks over
again to see what had happened and is
dumbfounded as he sees muzan standing on
his own and the surrounding area having
sustained heavy damage looking right
next to him he is even more baffled as
he sees gyomayn knocked into the
building he is hiding behind and that he
had lost his leg his horror only grows
as he sees sunimi has been flung into
the upper story of a tall building while
obani zunitsu and inosuke are all
unconscious in the rubble and geru's
sword arm has been severed kano's sword
falls to pieces as her sail falls off
and she falls to her knees with muzan
right in front of her she tries to urge
yourself to stand up and attack him but
she can only stare transfixed at him in
fear and shock the kakushi rushes from
his hiding place to attack butanjiro
interrupts muzan's attack with the
hanokami kagura beneficient radiance
cutting off muzan's arm the remaining
stump of flesh sizzles muzan looks at it
in concern as it does not grow back
immediately while tanjiru apologizes to
kano for being late handing her off to
the kikushi he turns to face muzan as he
says that the boy looks positively awful
and taunts him by saying that in his
current condition it is difficult to
tell who the demon is between the two of
them as he gazes at the boy muzan is
reminded of yoruichi and says that he
makes his skin crawl and tangero
challenges muzan saying that they should
finish it all tangido thought about how
his understanding drastically changed
after seeing the proper forms of the
hanokami kagura with his own eyes he
noticed wasted movements and the
variation of the angle of his wrists
differences in footwork and the
intervals between breaths he said that
yoruichi was a quiet and simple person
and when suyaku asked him to show her
the different forms he obliged sumiyoshi
made sure to memorize all of them
searing them into his memory left
breathless by the beauty of the
movements when he finished demonstrating
suyako and their children were
overflowing with excitement and yet a
week she bowed his head an embarrassment
sumyoshi asked yorowichi to come back
someday but when they parted the
demonstrator gave his hanafuda earrings
to sumiyoshi who realised that this
meant he would never see his friend
again this brought tears to his eyes and
he yelled out to yoroichi as he left
that they were grateful for him for
saving their lives and they would
continue on his legacy shouting that
yodewich's life was not without value
and that he shouldn't feel as if he
hadn't accomplished anything sumiyoshi
said he would pass down the sun
breathing and the earrings to his future
generations hearing all of this you know
which he turns around and thanks sumi
yoshi with a beaming smile in the prison
tangero stands in front of muzan and
thanks youichi for his actions including
sparing tamio whose own works had aided
the demon slayers in fighting the demon
and for showing his son breathing with
which tangido could assuredly defeat
muzan he thinks to himself at how he had
pondered over what their thirteenth form
could be and how he noticed the first
and twelfth form had similar names
recalling that his father had told him
that if he learned to breathe properly
then he would be able to dance forever
saying that his suspicions had been
confirmed when he saw muzan's current
state that performing all twelve forms
sequentially would complete a ring that
would result in their thirteenth form
tanjudo plans to attack muzan by
connecting all forms together and
continue to strike his brain and heart
until dawn realizing the gravity of his
task tangero understands how someone
such as the flame hashera who spoke with
yodowichi about his fight with muzan
could lose confidence believing that he
doesn't have yoruichi or even his own
father's skill and unsure on how he
would prevent muzan from escaping as he
did against yoruichi he asks how he can
do something even the great sun breather
couldn't do sterling himself tundra
resolves to try his best rallying
himself to keep his heart burning he
charges that muzan who begins to rapidly
attack him as he uses the sun breathing
seeing tajiri's attacks remind muzan of
yoruichi and he cries out that he is a
ghost he slashes around so violently
that the ground around them cracks into
pieces and he lands a hit on tanchira
who was pushed back
meanwhile tanjido notices how muzan had
been able to defeat everyone else he had
nine whips growing out from his back in
addition to his own two arms and he also
had eight even faster whips that grew
out of his thighs realizing that since
the demon could change shape he needs to
stop thinking of muzan as having a fixed
form to avoid being taken by surprise
tangible attempts to combine all the
forms to perform the 13th form by using
the sun breathing dance and raging sun
but is thoughted midway during the fire
wheel and pushed back yet again unfazed
tanjuro says that he will connect all
the forms as that's how they were
designed to be and resolves to succeed
muzan notes that living creatures are
able to tap into reserves of strengths
that they are not aware of to escape
death and looks on to see tanjiro doing
the same in an attempt to connect all
twelve forms of the sun breathing he
sees that tangero has turned his blade
bright red just as the other hashira had
but is unconcerned as he says that the
demon slayer's attacks are nowhere near
as powerful as those of yoroichi's as
the young demon slayer connects the sun
breathing dragon sun halo head dance and
firewheel he successfully manages to
connect six of the forms however muzan's
organs keep moving within his body
preventing him from attacking his torso
beginning to feel fatigued tangelo
heaves and slows down but he keeps
telling himself to focus on one second
at a time while connects the sun
breathing fake rainbow and burning bone
summer muza notices that tangero's
attacks begin to lose their accuracy and
surmises that he will soon lose his red
blade as well saying that he is yet
another swordsman who will never live up
to yoroichi nor reproduce the terrifying
technique that the old swordsman had
used against him launching another
attack towards tangido muzan manages to
connect and knock the boy back tangero
coughs up blood and muzan whips at him
yet again barely managing to evade it
swiftly regaining his footing tangerine
resumes his task of connecting together
all forms of the sun breathing this
puzzles muzan as he wonders why he is
struggling so much against one weak and
wounded human being who has grown weaker
by the second deducing that he himself
is also going slower as a one-on-one
fight wouldn't have lasted so long muzan
suspects it is an after effect of the
antidote injected into him by tamiyo
resolving to ask her himself as he had
absorbed herselves muzan seeks out her
remaining presence in his
subconsciousness finding the remnants of
the demon within him as a severed head
muzan holds it in his palm and asks her
what she had done as he believed the
drug had only made demons human again
tamiya's head reaffirms this but she
smiles evilly and says that she won't
tell him what else it does as that would
be something his multiple brains should
figure out enraged muzan crushes the
ruminants of tamiyu's head within his
hands and tries an alternative method to
figure out what had been done to him by
reading the memories lying in her
remaining cells muzan dives through her
memories and finds one of her in a lab
with yushiro and shinobu recognizing
shinobu as the poison user who had
fought doma muzan watches as she
suggests that they mix in two poisons
instead of one under the assumption that
he could withstand one of them with the
first poison being the ancestor to turn
demons into humans and the second one
being an aging potion tamiya had
concocted to make its victims older by
50 years every minute suddenly realizing
that he had been struggling against the
hashera and tanjuro because his body had
been diverting strength to combat
against his aging muzon attempts to
calculate how much he had aged noting
that it had been almost five hours since
tamiya had injected him with the drug
and the aging potion had only begun to
take effect three hours ago mozana is
shocked as he realizes that he has aged
by at least nine thousand years over the
whole battle recognizing that he should
have noticed this earlier when his color
did not return to his here muzan juix's
head to the side as he hears a crow
announce that there are 59 minutes until
dawn tangero keeps continuing by using
sun breathing solar heat haze
beneficient radiance clear blue sky fire
wheel raging sun and flame dance yelling
at tanjuno to stop jumping around muzan
attempts to attack the young demon
slayer again with renewed ferocity
batajiro dodges his attacks with sun
breathing fake rainbow and follows that
up with dance setting sun transformation
burning bones summer sun dragon sun halo
head dance and sunflower thrust with
that he successfully connected all 12
forms of the sun breathing and with a
new renewed hope he determines to keep
doing so until daybreak even with
greater speed and accuracy yushiro and
some of the demon slayers make their way
towards chachumaru's mangled body and
the demon reattaches the cat's head to
its body cradling it in his arms as it
recovers the accompanying demon slayers
are taken aback at this and asks yushiro
if chachumaru is also a demon and he
replies in the affirmative saying that
he and tamiya had turned it into a demon
shortly before the battle yushiro snaps
at the pier to stop dwardling and tend
to the injured they run off with vials
of tamiya's anti-muzan serum and get to
inosuke kano and zinetsu walking over to
gyome yushiro assesses the damage on the
hashera and notes that he has lost a lot
of blood in addition to his leg tying up
the wound to stem the bleeding yoshira
begins to worry as he declares that
gyome is in no position to fight even if
he does regain consciousness in time as
the blood loss and lack of equilibrium
will hinder him too much within over 50
minutes left till sunrise he thinks of
tamiya and asks her to help tanjiro in
his battle with muzan saying there is no
way the boy can last this long on his
own meanwhile tangero continues to
connect the different forms of the sun
breathing to defeat mozan as he matches
blows with a demon his left sleeve is
ripped off and he dodges back to avoid
the attacks seeing that it is not enough
to merely connect the forms tangido
realizes he must accurately target all
of muzan's hearts and brains to
effectively use the 13th form however
just as he attempts to see through muzan
to be able to do so he almost blacks out
due to lack of oxygen
shocked at this tangible quickly
attempts to regain his bearings and
sniff muzan out instead but slips and is
almost hit in an attack from the demon
before obanai intervenes and scoops him
out of harm's way quickly dodging all of
muzan's attacks obernai successfully
carries tangero out of danger with the
demon left angrily exclaiming at their
constant resistance asking why wouldn't
they just die already tanju's vision
clears up and he is able to see his
rescuer and he is overjoyed to recognize
the striped heyori of obanai this
quickly transforms into horror though as
he sees that the serpent hishera's face
has been mutilated with slashes across
his face and through his eyes morsified
tanjiru asks obani if he was injured
while saving him but the hashera hastily
explains that it was during muzan's
attack from before which had knocked out
all of the hashera continuing to dodge
attacks from muzan obanai tells tanjiro
to quit worrying about the others as the
boy offers to help out and says the
vision impairment will not affect him
greatly as one of his eyes has always
been weak and that he has a snake friend
kabul ramaru confirming that tanjuno has
recovered obani lets go of the boy and
quickly engages in battle with muzan who
would jump towards them with great fury
and tackles him one-on-one to tanjuro's
shark with kabul romaru's aid obernai
dodges all of the demon's attacks as the
surrounding building is destroyed and
tangier rushes to use sun breathing
again to help split muzan's attention
muzan notices that the snake is relaying
information to obanai which is allowing
the hashera to dodge his attacks and is
infuriated that such a simple animal is
able to read through his attacks tanjuro
and obani match muzan's attacks in
tandem and the demon is further annoyed
at being unable to kill such seriously
wounded humans realizing that it is due
to the aging potion continuing to evade
muzan's blows tajiro sees that the demon
has gradually gotten weaker but is
barely hanging on himself trying his
best to avoid oxygen deprivation
resolving to help obani who has helped
him so much already tangier was shocked
to see muzan's body begin to change
colour as old scars appear all over it
realizing that these were the wounds
yoda which he gave muzan so long ago
which the demon was never able to
recover from seeing that the demon had
been burnt at the cellular level and
that the wounds were his weak spots
tangible says that yarawichi was still
showing them the way muzan kibitsuji
reminisces over when he first saw
yeruichi recalling how he had first
thought the swordsman to be weak as he
exuded no drive or desire to fight muzan
or any hatred towards him he had never
expected yoruichi would be able to cut
off his head and wound him in such a way
that his body right down to the cells
would continue to hurt as if being hit
with sunlight continuing musan says it
was entirely out of the blue and no one
could have expected it and that yoruichi
had been the real monster instead of him
town to do rallies himself to take
advantage of muzan's growing exhaustion
and new found weak spots noticing that
the scars were all moving across the
demon's body tanjuro concludes that they
all mark his heart and brains and now
even though he cannot see through muzan
anymore due to lack of oxygen he can
still locate his organs and target them
trying to figure out a way to help obani
overcome his visual impairment tangier
decides to give the hashera one of
yushiro's seals and suddenly a crow
announces that there are 40 minutes left
until dawn upon hearing this muzan
immediately dashes away leaving the
battle in an attempt to secure himself
away from sunlight tangero quickly yells
this out to obanai who remembers that
muzan is not like a human who would act
on emotion and that he would cling to
his life first and foremost muzan begins
to further the distance between himself
and the demon slayers much to tangido's
frustration and suddenly passes through
a crowd of demon slayer corpses
trampling on them in his way this
frustrates tanjuro who reaches the
corpses and begins throwing all their
swords straight at muzan who quickly
slices through all of them with great
concern as passing attacks would be far
worse for him than slashes in his
current state the demon comes to an
abrupt halt as oberney drops from above
and stabs him through the top of his
chest jumping away just before muzan's
whips can swipe at him tangero slices at
the whips with sun breathing to ensure
overnight safety but has to throw away
yushiro's seals while defending from
muzan's ferocious attacks he yells at
overnight to jump to his right to grab
them but is relieved as kaburamaru
snatches them out of the air and obunai
takes them from him and wears one being
able to see better than before obani
begins to more effectively attack muzan
who begins to pant realizing that his
strength will soon give way muzan
becomes truly concerned as far away
nezuko reaches the outskirts of the town
where the battles going on with one of
her eyes having gone back to the way
they were when she was human nezuko
slowly makes her way panting towards the
town where the battle with muzan is
underway suddenly she flashes back to
her memory of muzan's attacks on the
kamado family after he had attacked all
of the members of the family and seen
that they had all apparently died due to
his attacks the demon notes that even
with a small dose of his blood he had
kept in his attacks none of them had
been able to become demons saying that
it would be difficult for him to make a
demon who could withstand his son
muzan left the kamado house unaware that
nezuko had survived more memories flood
into niziko's mind as she sees the
visions of the people and events she and
her brother tanjuro had encountered
during their journey including geyu
zakonji yushiro zenitsu and inosuke she
collapses to the ground unable to keep
walking and more memories flash through
her brain of the hashera meeting and
tanimi attempting to lure her in to
attacking him for his blood and finally
her memory of kagaya she remembers the
time at the butterfly mansion and
meeting its residents including shinobu
who during her stay once offered to give
her a closer look at the goldfish next
to her mexico thinks back to the
adventures with kyogiro tengen and their
time at the swordsman village finding
her footing niziko stands up with her
hand transforming back to a human hand
as she gets up with another memory of
her brother's hand as he told her that
he would save her no matter what neziko
holds her head sweating and grunting
profusely as she turns back into a human
declaring that she is niziko kamado
whose family was killed by a demon
meanwhile the battle of muzan rages on
as the demon rules the fact that he has
still been unable to finish off tangido
sensing that the other hashera are
slowly reviving muzan curses the demon
slayer core saying that they are like
linked beads of roziri which had always
been there trying to end him akron
announces that there are 35 minutes left
until dawn and upon hearing this he
attempts to split himself into several
pieces the way he had done in his fight
with yarawichi tanjiro recognizes this
technique and realizes what muzan is
about to do calling out to obani telling
him muzan's plan secretly worried that
if the demon successfully managed to
split himself then they would be unable
to stop him however muzan finds that he
is unable to do so and quickly realizes
that this is yet another side effect of
tamiyo's medicine he's shocked yet again
as he suddenly coughs up blood and
tamiya tells him that there were four
ingredients to the medicine and that
when the first three had weakened him
the fourth would take effect the fourth
being the destruction of musan's cells
with tommy sane and muzan's head with an
eerily menacing grin that the death he
hated so much throughout his life was
now terrifyingly near the apparition of
tamiya inside muzan's head tells him
that there is no need for them to be
stronger than him to kill him she says
that just as he would do anything to
survive then they who had suffered at
his hands would do anything to kill him
muzan notes that in regular
circumstances he would not be concerned
at the bright red blades of demon
slayers as they were all weaker than the
bright red blade of yoruichi and their
regeneration would not be so exhausting
for him he curses the medicine injected
into him by tamiyo as they now render
him susceptible to such exhaustion and
make the attacks of the demon slayers
far more potent than they normally would
be realizing the poison is different
from the one used on doma moussa notes
that it will take some time for him to
analyse the compound and counteracts it
suddenly he freezes and stands still
looking at the sky for a moment tanjunu
believes that the demon has finally
start to get exhausted and that tamiya's
medicine is finally taking effect he and
obama attempt to capitalize on this
opportunity and attack muzan but a giant
shock wave with lightning erupts out of
the demon's body and strikes everything
in close vicinity to mozan huge jaws
erupt from muzan's torso and run along
it diagonally to his back as he bears
fangs and glares at the destruction he
has caused with obana left stunned and
unable to move and tanjaro also
experiencing seizures meanwhile karaya
kanata and kawana also receive damage
from the attack due to the kasugai crow
being instantly killed in the blast
seeing this tenkan and shinjuku rush to
their aid karya bleeding from the nose
hastily says that he is fine and asks if
tanjudo and obanai are doing all right
shinjuku wonders if muzan somehow sensed
the location to be able to cause damage
kuana announces that there are 25
minutes left until dawn and korya asks
the demon slayers to hang in there and
that a final victory over muzan is
within their grasp tangero is still
unable to get up and wonders if his
lungs were damaged in the attack seeing
muzan walk away in anguish however the
demon stops in his tracks azinosuke
jumps in front of him saying that muzan
had really done it now and that he
wouldn't stand for it any longer enraged
muzan attacks inosuke with tangier
calling out for him but he is only able
to weakly flail his whips about pantene
muzan realizes that he has become too
tired after using this shockwave as
inosuke huffing and wheezing himself
says that kyomay had lost his leg trying
to protect them and that giu has lost
his arm continuing he tells the demon
that he had taken the lives of the other
demon slayers he had shared meals with
and ynosuke demands that he give them
all their lives back and carefully says
that if he couldn't then he would pay
for it with a million deaths muzan
launches an attack arinosuke who manages
to jump right out of the way but just as
he lands muzan sends his right arm whips
into the ground to catch inosuke from
below managing to ensnare the demon
slayer tanju attempts to get up and help
his friend but is unable to and says
that he will die first suddenly enosuke
is saved by zanetsu who slices through
muzan's arm whip and says that tanjido
is still alive as he can hear his
heartbeat yelling at tantido to continue
fighting and to stay alive zenechi tries
to bolster his spirits and tell him not
to die so that nezuko could become human
again and they could go back to the
house they used to live in muzan smacks
zenitsu into the building benignoscope
quickly slices his whip to prevent any
further damage the demon is infuriated
and attacks inosuke as well with tanjiro
desperate to help his friends through
his fights deducing that it could be a
blood demon art affecting his nervous
system tanjuro attempts to undo it by
stabbing himself in a non-vital area
with this mature and sword the blade
sizzles as it enters his body and tells
you to praise that it stops the shaking
enough for him to help out in the fight
muzan looks on azinetsu aninosuke
recover and note that he is unable to
raise his arms anymore as both geyu and
gyomay make their way to the battlefield
to resume their fight with him stopping
at nothing to finally kill muzan once
and for all everyone prays for the
success of those fighting muzan as
inosuke and zanitsu continue to attempt
to hold the demon back inosuke performs
his beast breathing fourth fang slice
and dice to chop off some of muzan's
whips as zenitso follows it up with a
thunderbreathing first form thunderclap
and flash god speed zinitsu notes that
he is losing his strength and he would
only be able to muster one more attack
with his full strength and unleashes a
thunder breathing seventh form
honokazuchi nokami but it only produces
a shallow cut and muzan saying that only
a bright red blade could deal sufficient
damage to muzan zenitsu falls to the
ground and muzon slashes adam inosuke
intercepts this attack with his beast
breathing fifth fang crazy cutting
following it up with his third fang
devourer in rapid succession
muzan is enraged and unleashes a weaker
shock wave from the mouth on his torso
that flings inosuke back before muzan is
able to do anything else however
kanchuro intervenes and performs the sun
breathing burning bones summer sun and
rapidly performing the raging sun fire
wheel beneficient radiance and dragon
sun halo head dance noting that muza
needs to allow his shock waves to charge
before using them tangier attempts to
use more of his sun breathing technique
but coughs up blood before he can attack
and is bailed out from muzan's counter
attack by inosuke who uses a beast
breathing sixth fang palacide bite which
allows tanjuro to unleash the sun
breathing dance clear blue sky and fake
rainbow zenitsu remembers his mentor
jigoro and asks him to give him the kick
he needs performing another thunder
breathing first form thunderclap and
flash sinitu attacks muzan but is
aggravated by the fact that he is too
slow azinosuke and tanjudo continue
their combined onslaught on muzan with
their respective sun breathing dance and
beast breathing fifth fang crazy cutting
in oscar gets knocked back but tanjido
is able to continue attacking muzan with
his sun breathing sitting sun
transformation and dragon sun halo head
dance with some help from zenitsu who
takes a blow intended for tanjido to
allow his friend to continue attacking
tangerine manages to perform successive
forms of the sun breathing dragon sun
halo head dance and raging sun to pin
mouse onto a wall with the sun breathing
sunflower thrust he is unable to perform
more techniques as the mouth of muzan's
chest attempts to take his blade
suddenly matsuri grabs muzan's left arm
and rips it clean off his body and anger
sacrificing her own arms in the process
cinema appears and quickly chops off
muzan's right arms as well with the
wind-breathing eighth form primary gale
slash undaunted muzon opens wide his
mouth from his torso to the top of his
head and tries to eat tanjuro with it
however urbanized steps in and takes the
bite instead protecting tanjuro as dawn
begins to break the sun begins to rise
as muzan kibitsuji is horrified at the
sight of it he unleashes another shock
wave and blows oberner and sunimi away
however tanjuru holds on but loses his
entire left arm resolving to keep
holding muzan down tangible attempts to
tighten his grip on his sword and make
it go bright red but is unable to do so
suddenly geyu tomioka appears behind him
and also grabs his blade to help keep
muzan pinned down with both demon
slayers holding onto the blade with
their combined might it turns the blade
red and muzan instantly starts to cough
up blood as the sun rises steadily the
demon quickly attempts to think of a way
to avoid disintegrating muzon attempts
to cover himself in a wall of flesh to
block the sunlight from hitting his skin
and transforms into a giant baby
as the flesh grows outward and begins to
swallow up tanjuro he throws his head
back to headbutt geyu out of the flesh's
growth and he gets slowed into it
alongside his blade as the water heshira
yells out to him muzan attempts to crawl
away from the scene into some shade and
kara ubiyashiki orders the remaining
members of the demon slayer corps to do
everything they could to hinder him
some lower ranking demon slays the right
bookcase on top of muzan's head from my
building slowing him down but he still
crawls forward a pair of kakushi ran
into him with some cars yelling at him
to die as karate orders them to all fall
back muzan crushes the cars and attempts
to crawl forward finding his way blocked
by some tram cars held by more kikushi
amazon attempts to overcome this hurdle
as well as he slowly begins to sizzle as
mozan attempts to crush the kakushi
behind the tram cars with his first
karai orders them to fall back and stay
alive sunimi intervenes and slices off
muzon's right arm with wind-breathing
ninth form editing typhoon however the
cut was too shallow to do any more
damage as muzan continues to try and
climb over the cars to avoid dying
kyomei throws his chain around the
demon's neck and with the help of some
kakushi pulling on him the stone hashira
attempts to pull the demon down onto the
ground with brute force he successfully
does so and cry yells for the demon to
finally burn and disintegrate as kawana
ubishiki prays for the victory
determined not to die muzan continues
his resistance and begins to dig
underground to avoid the sunlight geyu
and sunimi work in tandem to attack the
demon and strike him with
water-breathing tenth form constant flux
and wind-breathing fifth form cold
mountain wind they are joined by obanai
who unleashes the serpent breathing
fourth form twin-headed reptile but all
three are only able to inflict minor
damage with everyone at their limits
guillermo's chain shatters and muzan
begins to crawl deeper down with the
others left too exhausted to further
impede him suddenly tanjulo tightens his
grip on his blade and attacks muzan from
the inside causing him to rear up in
agony going straight up into the
sunlight and the demon finally begins to
disintegrate as he cries out the sun
rises on a new day as muzan kibitsuji
finally disintegrates and everyone
heaves a sigh of relief crying as their
battle is finally over kara ubiyashiki
orders for the injuries of the wounded
to be tended to before passing out
himself gyome refuses to accept any help
from the junior demon slayers or kokushi
and asks for the injuries of the younger
fighters to be tended to first as he
knows that his fate is inevitable he
begins to see all of the children he
used to care for at the temple up here
before him and they tell him they had
always wanted to apologize for the day
they had been attacked by the demon
saying that they knew they had hurt him
they explained that they had not
intended to run away but were instead
trying to protect him as he was the
blind one one child says that he was
trying to go outside to get farming
tools as a weapon while another say she
had been trying to go and call for help
guillerme hears their explanations and
accepts them as they continue on and
tell him that they also had a reason for
driving out kaigaku their nigh which
they would have not told them about had
they lived till the morning was fully
wishing the next day had dawned for the
children as well gyome apologizes to
them for being unable to protect them
the children tell him not to apologize
saying that they love him and that they
had been waiting for him this entire
time thanking them gyome says that they
can all now move on together and passes
away with a smile on his face leaving
the kikushi in tears matsuri comes to
and finds herself in open eyes arms and
asks him if they had won
he tells her that they did and she is
relieved but tells him that she could
not feel anything more and that she
would die soon urbana responds that he
would also be dying soon and that she
wouldn't be alone anguished at this she
tells him not to die apologizing for not
being of much use in the fights
reporting though that that was not true
obama reminds her of the first time they
met when matsuri had gotten lost in the
mansion and she recalls that obani had
helped her overnight rebuffs saying that
it was the other way around and that she
had been the one who saved him he tells
her that despite all of the troubles she
had gone through to become a hashira she
had still been so normal when they had
met and that she was still capable of
enjoying the things around her like a
regular human being this had made obani
feel like a regular boy as well as he
cherished his time with her saying that
he was sure the other heshira had felt
the same way he tells her that her
cheerfulness had saved many people
around her and that she had not been
useless at all but begins to cry
and says that meals had tasted better
with obanai as he had always looked at
her with great affection she asks him if
she could be his bride if they are ever
reborn and obino replies that she could
definitely be if she would have him as
hers and that he would make her happy
and protect her meanwhile sanemi sees a
vision of genya and his siblings all
playing together happily in heaven but
looks around for his mother who is
nowhere to be seen turning behind to his
right he senses his mother shizu
shinozugawa standing there and pulls her
hand from the darkness telling her to
join her children however she refuses
saying that she didn't deserve to go to
heaven as she had attacked her children
smiling serenely sanemi tells her that
he would go along with her saying that
genya would be saddened to see him so
soon he attempts to go with her but her
hand is wrenched away by his father who
says that he would be the one
accompanying their mother tsunemi yells
at his father to let go of his mother
but he simply responds that sanemi isn't
ready to die yet and that he was extra
tough senemy regains consciousness into
kakushia overjoyed to see this enosuke
regains consciousness as well and bites
kikoshi who attempted to help him while
coughing up blood zenitsu tells the
kakushi tending to him to tell nezuko
that he loved her and was brave fighting
to the very end calling her his wife as
others point out that he's actually not
married giu gets up and tries to find
tajido but looks forward to see the boy
as kneeling still holding his blade and
having bled heavily after losing his arm
the kakushi tearfully informed giyu that
tanju was no longer breathing and had no
pulse he was greatly saddened tearing up
and kneeling down in front of tanjuro he
grabs the boy's remaining hand and
apologizes for having failed to protect
him he was always the one who ended up
receiving protection he apologizes to
niziko for being unable to protect her
brother not knowing that she had arrived
at this scene and was carefully running
for her brother from behind him as death
dwells muzan kivitsuji recounts how
death had always been close to him and
that his heart had stopped many times
even while he had been inside of his
mother's womb
he had been stubborn but when he was
about to be cremated he suddenly began
writhing around and crying for the first
time and thus had been speared the demon
feels relieved as he says that he had
finally achieved what he had been
waiting to make happen for so long
admitting that what he could do on his
own was limited he thinks of kokaya
ubishiki and concedes that what the
master had told him was correct saying
that everything that lives must die and
their only feelings were external muzan
says that he did not remember even a
single human being he had killed but
their feelings had passed on and stayed
alive even managing to conquer him being
moved to tears at the fact that the
feelings of all the people had
vanquished him muzana's resigned to his
inevitable fate however he says that his
own feelings are external and undying
just like anyone else's and he extends
his hand towards tanjido who was there
with him and still alive as he gives all
of his blood to tanjuro muzan says that
if the boy survived this he would become
the strongest demon ever since he was
the brother of nezuko kamado the first
demon to develop an immunity to sunlight
and also the one capable of using the
breath style of yoruichi
he slowly disintegrates muzan tells
tanjido to make his dream come true and
destroy the demon seiko in his place as
geyu tomiyoka kneels in front of tanjiro
and the surrounding kikushi shed tears
one of them suddenly gapes in shock as
the tumor from tangible's head
disappears and he opens his eyes to
reveal a demonic gaze to everyone's
shock tangent regenerates his left arm
and swipes at the kakushi next to him
begin reacts quickly and pushes the
kakushi out of harm's way the other
kokushi look on interfere and ask why
tanjiro is acting in such a manner the
boy stands drooling profusely enjoying
his newfound fangs and claws his demons
layer mark mutates and goes down to move
past the bridge of his nose with another
identical mark growing upwards from the
bottom of his neck almost to meet in the
middle similar to kokoshibo's mark giu
rushes forward and yells at the other
kokushi to get away from tanchiro as the
boy looks to swipe adam suddenly the sun
shines brightly from the sky and tantro
double takes to look at her he begins to
burn and ride on the ground with his
swipe at the kakushi going off target
but still managing to rip off the lower
half of his mask as gee gets in front of
the kokushi he tells him to run away as
he prepares to face this new threat
yelling for everyone who is still
conscious to grab weapons and begin
fighting everyone else looks on from
afar with confusion at the sudden
commotion unaware of tanjiru's fate when
geu suddenly announces to them that
tanjido has become a demon he says that
they need to pin tanjiru down and burn
him in the sun before he could kill
anyone tanjido suddenly attempts to find
shade to stop burning but giu intercepts
him by stabbing him from the side and
dragging him into the ground with the
boy clutching at his hair noting to
himself that if he had not been
interrupted by the sun tangent would
have surely killed the kakushi he was
fully begs in his mind for tangier to
stay who he was and die as a human
suddenly tanjiru stops burning and goo
looks on in shock as the boy takes
advantage of the hashira's surprise to
swipe at him he narrowly dodges but his
chin is grazed and tajiro follows up
with another swipe that is intercepted
by inosuke who yells at his friend and
asks him what he is doing gaeu attempts
to stand up but feels dizzy from his
blood loss and cannot do so enough
stands over him and tries to remind
tanjito that giulio is the ally azinetsu
also approaches the saiyan supported by
kikoshi tajiro crouches down and a third
demonstrator mark appears from the other
right side of the head and he bears
fangs at ignoskay who can only look on
quietly at what has become of his best
friend zenitsu looks on and disbelief at
the scene and says that everyone else is
tired and unable to continue fighting
asking for tanchiro to think of niziko
tanjo leaps forward to attack inosuke
who prepares to fight him anosuke thinks
back to his time together with tanjido
and says that they are all comrades like
brothers who would pull each other back
if one of them started going down the
wrong path stealing himself by thinking
that no matter how difficult it was they
would always walk down the right path
zenetsu yells at tanchiro to stop as
inosuke thinks to himself that he would
strike tanjido down and stop him himself
suddenly hit by a memory of tantru
offering him some fish to eat together
with a smile on his face enosuke stops
mid-swipe at tangero's neck and is
unable to complete his attack tearing up
insane that it was no use and that he
could not attack tanjuro geu inosuke and
zunitsu look on in shock as nezuko runs
forward and hugs the now demonified
tanjido as he sinks his claws and fangs
into his sister she begins to bleed out
but tanturo does not proceed to drink
her blood crying niziko hugs tangido and
apologizes to him for all the hardships
he had to endure to make her human again
she encourages him to resist becoming a
demon and says that going through all of
the suffering was quite difficult but to
never give up as nezuko tells him to
come with her tangero starts sinking his
claws in deeper and lets out a wild howl
enosuke and zinetsu rush forward to help
nezuko to try and bring their friend
back zenitsu grabs tanjuno from behind
and begs him to stop herself and that
she had become human again as he tells
him that she might die if he continued
further tanjiru lets out another how but
this time is interrupted by nosuke
repeatedly hitting him on the head
saying that tanjuri was not the kind of
person who would hurt his sister enosuke
tells his friend to snap out of it and
to go back to being his kind usual self
angered tanjuro lets out another feral
howl and sends a shock wave that flings
enosukes you and gee you back as niziko
desperately clings on to her brother
she falls to the ground as tanjaro gets
on all fours and releases bone whips
similar to those of muzans from his back
she begs him to keep fighting his
newfound demonic tendencies however he
still swings a whip towards the netsu
geyu intercepts the attack by performing
the water-breathing fourth form striking
tide saving zinetsu and the kakushi
propping him up thinking to himself that
things have progressed too far with
tanjuro having bitten into niziko and
learning the taste of blood here kieru
aims to kill tanjido however the water
hashera acknowledges that neither bright
red blades nor the sun will work on
tanjiro anymore leaving him virtually
indestructible suddenly tajiro charges a
ball of pure energy from his mouth
nezuko sees this and desperately tries
to stop his brother from committing any
murders telling him that he has to stop
niziko puts her hand in front of
tanzano's mouth to block the attack and
it goes off course hitting the ground
instead gee was able to dodge as initsu
calls out to nezuko in concern her
entire left hand and forearm begin to
bleed profusely as a result of blocking
the attack and she yells at her brother
to stop as he gets on all fours
attempting to stop him from using his
whips nisiko puts her hand on her
brother's back and tangier is only able
to strike the ground again looking on in
shock understanding begins to dawn on
giyu as he sees that somewhere inside
tangerine was fighting his demonic urges
as he was avoiding doing any lethal
damage to nizuko geru decides to try and
bring tanjiro back to his senses though
he is unsure he would be able to perform
such a miraculous feed meanwhile from
behind the shade of a nearby building
yoshido looks on at the scene cursing
muzan for continuing to torment people
even after his death seeing that his
blood demon art would disintegrate with
sunlight ushira feels powerless to stop
the carnage suddenly he sees kano
lumping forward to the scene of the
battle looking on at the sights of the
two siblings kano tears up and feels
sorry for them she reaches for the vial
of medicine in her front pocket and is
relieved to find it undamaged thinking
back to when she received it from
shinobu kano remembers the former
insectoshira telling her that she made
an extra vial of tamiya's medicine and
the fear that there might not be enough
lefeneziko once things had settled she
tells shinobu that this must be the
reason why she has still got one eye
quickly analyzing tangido kano assesses
that since he had only just become a
demon she would be able to dodge his
attacks even with just one eye kano
activates the flower breathing final
form equinencial vermilion eye and
charges towards tanchito with geyu doing
a double take and recognizing the move
as kane's tangible swipes it kano but
she evades it by back flipping over the
boy and injects the medicine into him
just as he redirects his arm and then
slashes edu torso as she begins to bleed
kano tells tanjido that it is enough and
it is time for him to come back to them
saying that he must not make mizuko cry
kano falls to the ground or they thud as
something begins to stir inside
tangent's consciousness upon hearing
nezuko's name and their medicine begins
to take effect nezuko tearfully calls
out to her brother to return so that
they may finally return home tangero
stirs in his subconscious and responds
that he is very tired and wishes to go
home as well tangier prays to the god to
return home saying he only wants to go
home with his little sister but as he
raises his arm to reach forward eyes
grow on the flesh growths that cover his
body and begin to speak the voice of
muzan attempts to dissuade tanchiro from
returning to his loved ones asking what
would happen after he returned to them
muzan tells him that his entire family
is dead and that there is no point in
returning home batantry responds that he
still has memories of the happy days
there he tells the demon lord that their
memories will never disappear as long as
he and nezuko are still alive and that
is why he has to go back tantru
continues to slowly reach forward as
muzan tries harder to dissuade tanchito
he lies to him and says that the boy has
killed nizuko unpersuaded tanjida calls
muzan's bluff and says that nezuko is
alive telling him he lies his deceased
friends then all give him a push to the
back to raise him up muzan tells them
not to interfere and continues to try
and mislead tangido saying that they all
now hate him and don't want him to
return for what he has done after
becoming a demon muzan continues to try
and discourage the young demon slayer
vatanjida responds then he wants to
apologize to everyone for hurting them
and muzan retorts saying that they would
not forgive him then telling the demon
slayer that it was not for him to decide
but tanto perseveres and continues to
move forward saying that he could smell
all of his friends being concerned for
him growing more frustrated muzan tells
tanchodo to be silent and says that he
is the inheritor of his will so he
should not look forward or try to find
any hope but instead should embrace life
as a demon telling the boy that he would
die in a few short years because he had
manifested their demonstra mark muzan
urges him to think only of himself and
live forever however the boy refuses and
says that he never wanted to live
forever and that he only wanted to
return to his friends and live as a
human admittedly refusing to give up on
trying to mislead tanchiro muzan tries
to manipulate him further and asks if
the boy really wishes to return to her
life after everyone else has died
grabbing the head of tanjuro in his
hands he asks tanjido if he wants to
live on without losing anything more
hands push tanchiro forward and he
smells the scent of wisteria flowers at
first believing it is shinobu kocho he
tears up as he sees nezuko's arms
reaching out for him reaching forward
himself to meet her tantalum grabs
nezuko's hand and she attempts to pull
him forward but muzan grabs his arm and
tries to force him away saying that they
had finally conquered the sun and that
tanjuro would go with him saying that he
was a rare being muzan tells him to hear
the cries of the dead and that they all
resented him for being the only one who
could move on and keep his life
rebuffing this tanjuro says that they
were not such people and that instead
they had been willing to sacrifice their
lives for others saying that while they
were sad and suffered they did not wish
their fathers as tanjuna begins to be
taken away muzan grabs at his torso and
tries to pull him back but in vain as
the hands of geyu zenitsu andy nosuke
join nezuko to pull him up as even more
hands reach out to pull tangero up muzan
finally loses his grip and tangier
regains consciousness to find niziko
looking down at him with tears in her
eyes with his friends and the kakushi
surrounding him nezuko calls out
tanjiro's name and he apologizes to
everyone for having brought them harm
everyone begins to cheer upon hearing
his voice and inosuke tells tanjido that
he hadn't caused them any significant
harm at all zinetsu begins sobbing and
says that he would make tanjudo pay for
his entire life for what he had done to
him and calls nezuko his wife much to
her shock and consternation gee you
heaves a sigh of relief and who she
holds him to keep him stable as nezuko
hugs her brother they both smile through
the tears and ikakushi wakes kanu up to
tell her the good news kanye regains
consciousness and smiles as she looks on
at tanjuro with tanjuru thinking to
himself that he was glad that she was
still alive enosuke grabs tanjiro's head
and begins to sob as yushira pulls out
tamiya's hairpin and begins to weep
saying that it was all finally over
three months after the battle against
muzan the world is now free of evil
demons and the survivors of the battle
continue living despite all they lost
tanjunu recovers at the butterfly
mansion and sees the cherry blossoms in
bloom alongside nizikou enosuke and
zinitsu sleep peacefully at the other
end of tanjiru's beard as nasco says
that their flowers look very pretty
examining tanjido's left hand now
horribly shriveled nezuko asks her
brother how it feels and he responds
that he cannot feel anything on his left
arm beneath his elbow so he cannot use
the hand anymore then he points to his
right eye and says that while it looks
okay he cannot see anything out of it
tangier asks niziko how she is doing and
she responds with a beaming smile that
she feels perfectly fine still feeling
guilty though over how being attacked
her when he was a demon tanjito
apologizes to niziko for attacking her
niziko pouts and says that no one cares
if he turned into a demon and attacked
everyone saying that she was just glad
he was human again she tells him that if
he apologizes for it again she would
flick him on his forehead he tells her
that gee you told him he feared all was
lost when tanjore had but neziko and she
laughs saying she had felt the same way
then he tells her that you shiro had
told him that it was quite lucky
actually because they had shinobu
kochi's medicine with them and because
neziko had already been a demon before
she had also developed an immunity to
muzan's cells
these words fly over nezuko's head as
tanjuna reiterates what yushiro had told
him the demon had told tanjudo that had
they not shinobu's medicine or had
nezuko not been the one that he had
bitten then he may have never become
human again yoshiro had been impressed
that tanjo hadn't completely lost
himself since he had been more powerful
than either muzan or neziko even
concretely son in an instant he told
tanjido that he admired him for having
fought valiantly and the boy had
stammered over his words at the
compliment modestly saying that he had
received a lot of help yushiro had told
him that it was a joke and not to take
it seriously before picking up
chachumaru and leaving
tanjuro had called out to him before he
left though asking him to stay alive and
to not die as he was the only one who
could keep tamiya's memory alive tangero
had not heard from the demons since then
and was getting slightly worried about
him suddenly remembering geyu he asks
nezuko where he is and she responds that
he is all right and was with karaya
ubiya shiki meanwhile korya began the
final hashera meeting with the two
remaining hashera giyutomioka and
tsunemi shinozugawa both in attendance
quraya announces that the demon slayer
corps was disbanding from that moment on
the ub sheikis expressed their gratitude
to the hashera and the demon slayers for
their centuries of service and bow
before them with both hashera protesting
this telling the ubishikis that they
were the one that kept the core together
and that they did not want any thanks
the hashera instead expressed their
gratitude towards the
geyu tells coria that he was excellent
at his job and that his father and
ancestors would be proud and the
ubishiki tears up at these words as
kariah thanksgiving's compliment the two
hashira look on at each other and smile
as their long journey had finally ended
meanwhile tengen uzue and his three
wives visit tanjuro being glad to meet
them again suma rushes forward to greet
mizuko and starts loudly doting over the
girl so much that makio hits her for
being too loud much to her frustration
she asks tengan if he saw makio hit her
but he responds that he missed it tengen
tells tanjiro to visit them when he got
better giving them their address and
hinatsuru handed him a snack shinjuru
speaks with tanjido and thanks him for
using kyogioro's handguard on his blade
during the final battle saying it would
have made his son quite happy tanjuru
humbly replies that kyogiro's words had
been quite inspiring for him and that
they had helped him throughout his
journey cenaxis suddenly wakes up and
finds that the swordsmiths are waiting
outside of tanturo's room saying that
they come every day and creep him out
his shock only grows as a group of
kokushi also arrive and they all enter
the room filling it to the brim zenith
you hold on to tangero oh my god man
zunitsu holds on to tangido scared at
the turn of the event as tanjiru smiles
at the sight of more of his comrades
meanwhile enosuke sneaks away into the
kitchen and grabs his snack as owie is
busy cooking he swipes some of the food
and she catches him saying he was
stealing again and then offered him a
plate of prepared food telling him to
stop stealing food inosuke is quite
impressed at how quickly she caught him
and wonders if she's strong and then
smiles serenely as he begins to dig into
the food presented to him kano stands in
the garden in front of a cherry blossom
tree and tangier comes to meet her
saying it was a beautiful tree she tells
him that it was called victory and had
been planted by the first user of their
flower breathing and she had come to
tell it that they had finally defeated
muzan tangero asks her how she is doing
and she responds that she still has some
vision left in her eyes and that her
wound was better saying that even
tsunami had given her obanised pet snake
kaburamaru to take care of as the
serpent slithers out of her collar
sunimi meets nezuko and she greets him
asking him how his injuries were to
which he responds that they are fine
sanemi apologizes to niziko for having
passed out after muzan's defeat leaving
them to deal with tangido on their own
but she cheerfully responded that it was
no trouble and that she had once passed
out for two whole years saying that it
was nothing compared to that she then
says that she loved sleeping which makes
sunimi think of genya shinozugawa when
he was a child and when he had told
tsunemi that he loved sleeping because
he didn't get hungry
sanemi smiles and pets in izuko's head
telling her to take care as inetsu
jealously looked on from around the
corner of the hallway and raged at
sanemi's actions tanjiro and nizikou
find geu and sakonji and greet them glad
to finally be reunited later on they go
and pay their respects at the graves of
olivier fallen before they depart the
butterfly mansion for the kamado
residents sinitsu complains that it will
take all day but refuses to let inosuke
do it with his faster method saying he
will not pay proper respect once they
were finished and on their way to the
kamado household enosuke asks zinetsu
what he was carrying on his back as
zenitsu responded that it was his
gramps's remains puzzled and oscar asked
what remains are and if they are edible
to zinetsu's disgust on their way back
they meet saburo one of the people who'd
live near the kamado family and he
greets them tearfully when they had
arrived back at the kamado household
they found flowers are growing outside
the house and they pay their respects to
the other kamados by kneeling in front
of the flowers and praying they begin
their new life at the kamado household
and time leaps forward to a large modern
city
well that officially brings us to the
very end of the sunrise countdown arc
and the entire demon slayer series in
general explained if you guys have
enjoyed this video and my series as well
like entirely then make sure you do hit
that subscribe button as honestly i've
had unrealistic growth over the last few
weeks and i can't thank you all for the
amount of support that i have been
getting um like honestly the
demonstrator series i'm probably going
to give it like a strong solid like
seven out of ten i know when it comes to
the author and a lot of like home stuff
that was going on and she had to kind of
like speed up the ending there and i
tried to like kind of purvey that in
like my video also as well but like
trying to give that kind of like rush
sense to it because i did feel when i
read it it kind of had like that rushed
sense to like the whole thing slowly
sped up further and further as it got
throughout the story and then learning
later on obviously that the author had
some you know like personal issues and
that's kind of why she actually sped the
story up kind of makes sense now so i i
hope i was able to convey that in a good
enough way it has taken me like six
videos or like five videos i'm not too
sure i've lost count since the beginning
of the series to cover up to here and if
you guys want me to go over obviously
the start of the demonstra series before
uh like the stuff that i've done here
obviously then do let me know down below
and i'll do that and then i'll compile
it into a massive video that'll be like
too long it'll just be too long
obviously if you guys are interested in
other series as well then do be sure to
chuck a comment down there and let me
know what you guys want to see i am
going to be going over attack on titan
next in the final season so obviously if
you're interested in that then
be sure to be on the lookout for that i
thought i'd add this in here i also
decided not to add you know obviously
chapter 205 which is the very final
chapter of the entire series because if
you guys are interested go and read it
yourself it's a it's an amazing chapter
which kind of just shows the future
of the entire world with like the the
lineage i think it's only like one or
two generations ahead and i think coria
is like the oh you carter they're broke
like the oldest living person in the
world quite cool saying you know like
descendants of them being all together
and the stuff that they said would
happen in the past kind of happened in
the future i like that kind of stuff and
it brings you know like butterflies to
my stomach or however you want to put it
so i enjoyed it at the end of the day
and that's all i'm looking for in a
series but yeah for now it's been your
professional degenerate diabolo and i
will see you all in april
bye
[Music]